This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2014, President Obama expanded the Pacific Remote Island's Marine National Monument, making it the largest marine preserve in the world at the time. The Pacific Remote Island's Marine Preserve is farther from human settlement than any other US territory. The President's expansion of the reserve today will close 490,000 square miles of largely undisturbed ocean to commercial fishing and underwater mining. And if you look at a map, the preserve really is nowhere near the United States. It's thousands of miles from the U.S. mainland.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2014年，奥巴马总统扩大了太平洋偏远岛屿海洋国家纪念碑的范围，使其成为当时世界上最大的海洋保护区。太平洋偏远岛屿海洋保护区距离人类定居点比任何其他美国领土都要远。总统今天对该保护区的扩建，将使49万平方英里基本未受干扰的海洋禁止商业捕捞和海底采矿。如果你看地图，这个保护区确实离美国本土很远，距离美国大陆有数千英里之遥。
That's reporter Emmett Fitzgerald. It's not even that close to Hawaii. Yet somehow President Obama was able to protect this piece of ocean in the name of the United States. And to understand how the United States has jurisdiction over these waters in the middle of the Pacific Ocean, we've got to go all the way back to the 19th century. When, for a brief period, US sailors scoured the oceans looking for rocky islands covered in Guano. Which a lot of people think of as just bad poop.
那是记者埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。它甚至离夏威夷都不算近。然而，奥巴马总统却以美国的名义保护了这片海域。要了解美国是如何在太平洋中部对这些水域拥有管辖权的，我们必须追溯到19世纪。当时，美国水手曾有一段短暂的时间，在海洋中四处搜寻覆盖着鸟粪的岩石岛屿。很多人认为这只是糟糕的粪便。
I think most people think of Guano as bad poop, but in this case we're talking about birds and sea birds, so sea bird poop. That's Paul Sutter, I'm a professor of history at the University of Colorado at Boulder. In the mid-1800s, the United States became obsessed with the quest to find and sell Guano to use as fertilizer on farms. People believed it would revolutionize farming, and it did, at least for a little while, but the quest for bird poop ultimately had even bigger ramifications.
我想大多数人认为鸟粪就是糟糕的粪便，但在这种情况下，我们谈论的是鸟类和海鸟，所以是海鸟粪。我是保罗·萨特，科罗拉多大学博尔德分校的历史学教授。在19世纪中期，美国沉迷于寻找并出售鸟粪作为农场肥料的追求。人们相信这会彻底改变农业，事实也确实如此，至少在短时间内是这样，但对鸟粪的追求最终产生了更大的影响。
The use of sea bird poop as fertilizer starts in South America. Well, it originates with deposits off the coast of Peru, off southwest Peru, and particularly three islands there called the Chinchah Islands. The Chinchah Islands are in the middle of a nutrient-rich current with tons of plankton and massive schools of fish. And there are sea birds that live on the islands, getting fat off all these fish.
将海鸟粪用作肥料始于南美洲。它起源于秘鲁海岸外，秘鲁西南部外海，特别是那里被称为钦查群岛的三个岛屿。钦查群岛位于富含营养的洋流之中，那里有大量的浮游生物和成群的鱼类。岛上生活着海鸟，它们靠吃这些鱼长得肥硕。
They're gorging themselves on anchovies, and they're defecating all over these islands across hundreds if not thousands of years. And it almost never rains on the Trench Island, so over time the Guano just keeps piling up. And as a result, these deposits built up to almost a hundred feet deep in places. That's the size of a ten-story building of poop. For centuries, the Ketchua people in Peru would mine these Guano mountains and spread the bird poop out on their fields. And it worked. They were really successful farmers. And the Spanish who colonized the region began noticing this and really dabbled in it. But scientists in Europe didn't really get interested in Guano until the famed Prussian
它们大肆吞食凤尾鱼，并在数百甚至数千年的时间里在这些岛屿上到处排泄。钦查群岛几乎从不下雨，所以随着时间的推移，鸟粪不断堆积。结果，这些沉积物在某些地方堆积到了近一百英尺深。那相当于一座十层楼高的粪便。几个世纪以来，秘鲁的克丘亚人一直在开采这些鸟粪山，并将鸟粪撒在他们的田地里。这很有效。他们是非常成功的农民。殖民该地区的西班牙人开始注意到这一点，并真正涉足其中。但欧洲的科学家直到著名的普鲁士
naturalist Alexander von Humboldt visited the Peruvian coast in 1804. He saw laborers unloading ships full of bird poop, and he took a sample and brought it back with him to Europe. In the early 19th century, a German chemist named Eustus von Liebig began arguing that soil fertility basically came down to just a few critical nutrients. Nitrogen, phosphorus, and potassium. And that soil fertility can be restored or maintained by adding those nutrients, those chemical or mineral nutrients, back to the soil.
博物学家亚历山大·冯·洪堡在1804年访问秘鲁海岸时，才真正对鸟粪产生兴趣。他看到工人们正在卸下装满鸟粪的船只，于是取了样本带回欧洲。19世纪初，一位名叫尤斯图斯·冯·李比希的德国化学家开始提出，土壤肥力基本上取决于几种关键营养素：氮、磷和钾。通过将这些化学或矿物营养素添加回土壤中，可以恢复或维持土壤肥力。
Peruvian guano had really high concentrations of all three of these nutrients, especially nitrogen. It was the agricultural analog to discovering gold. The Peruvians began to mine guano on a commercial scale, and they struck deals with British merchants to sell Peruvian Guano back in Europe. And they set up shop on the Chinchot Islands, and they initially rely on local semi-coarse labor, but eventually they get into importing Chinese laborers. This is a form of bonded contract labor, so they're also paid very little.
秘鲁鸟粪中这三种营养素的浓度非常高，尤其是氮。这在农业上相当于发现了黄金。秘鲁人开始大规模商业化开采鸟粪，并与英国商人达成协议，将秘鲁鸟粪销往欧洲。他们在钦查群岛设立了据点，最初依赖当地的半强迫劳动力，但最终开始进口中国劳工。这是一种契约劳工形式，所以他们的报酬也非常微薄。
It's a very abusive labor system. They're misled in terms of the terms of this deal. The miners lived on the islands, intense and bamboo shacks. And they hacked away at the Guano deposits with shovels and pickaxes for up to 17 hours a day. They're chipping away at this Guano. They're sending it down giant shoots, often right into the holds of ships.
这是一种非常虐待性的劳动制度。他们在合同条款方面受到了误导。矿工们住在岛上的帐篷和竹棚里。他们每天工作长达17小时，用铁锹和镐头挖掘鸟粪沉积物。他们凿开这些鸟粪，通过巨大的滑槽将其送下，通常直接送入船舱。
This is incredibly accurate, caustic stuff. It gets in their lungs, and it's really debilitating. But soon, farmers all across Europe were using Peruvian Guano on their fields. Two of the companies profiting the most off this new trade were WJ Myers from Liverpool, and Gibbs' sons from London. There was a little slogan that said, the house of Gibbs made their dibs selling the turds of foreign birds. Word of the fertilizing power of seabird poop eventually reaches the United States.
这是一种极其刺鼻、腐蚀性强的物质。它进入他们的肺部，非常损害健康。但很快，整个欧洲的农民都在他们的田地里使用秘鲁鸟粪。从这项新贸易中获利最多的两家公司是利物浦的WJ迈尔斯公司和伦敦的吉布斯父子。当时有一句小口号说：“吉布斯家族靠兜售外国鸟类的粪便发了财。”海鸟粪的肥力功效最终传到了美国。
Where commercial farming, and particularly unslave plantations in the south, had stripped the soil of a lot of its nutrients. Historically, farmers would plant cover crops, practice crop rotation, or raise cattle for manure production in order to keep their soil healthy, or they would just farm a field until they had exhausted its nutrients and then move on to a new piece of land. But British merchants began advertising a new product that would help American farmers stay in one place and maximize their yields. Peruvian guano. Planners begin to experiment with it as a way of increasing their yields, and in some
在那里，商业农业，特别是南方的奴隶制种植园，已经耗尽了土壤中的大量养分。历史上，农民会种植覆盖作物、实行轮作，或饲养牲畜以生产粪肥来保持土壤健康，或者他们只是耕种一片土地直到耗尽其养分，然后转移到一块新土地。但英国商人开始推销一种新产品，可以帮助美国农民留在原地并实现产量最大化：秘鲁鸟粪。种植园主开始尝试用它来增加产量，在某些
cases have really good results. Soon agricultural publications in the US were praising guanos' magical properties, and farmers throughout the country began using it to fertilize their fields. By the late 1840s, the United States was in the grips of what historians have called Guano Mania, importing tens of thousands of tons of bird poop every year. The US was bird shit crazy. But because British firms had a monopoly over the Peruvian guano trade, guano was expensive. And so farmers began to petition Washington
情况下取得了非常好的效果。很快，美国的农业出版物开始赞美鸟粪的神奇特性，全国各地的农民开始用它来给田地施肥。到19世纪40年代末，美国陷入了历史学家所称的“鸟粪狂热”，每年进口数万吨鸟粪。美国简直对鸟粪着了迷。但由于英国公司垄断了秘鲁鸟粪贸易，鸟粪价格昂贵。因此，农民开始向华盛顿请愿，
to help them get cheap guano. At one point, the president of the United States millered film more in his 1850 annual address, makes guano security a kind of important point of that address. Peruvian guano has become so desirable and article to the agricultural interests of the United States that it is the duty of the government
要求帮助他们获得廉价的鸟粪。有一次，美国总统米勒德·菲尔莫尔在1850年的年度国情咨文中，将鸟粪安全作为该咨文的一个重要点。秘鲁鸟粪已成为美国农业利益中如此令人向往的商品，政府有责任
to employ all the means properly in its power for the purpose of causing that article to be imported into the country at a reasonable price. But, Philmore was mostly talk, and guano prices continued to soar. And so US businessmen start to take matters into their own hands. They begin going out looking for other islands with new sources of Guano. And these bird poop prospectors come across an uninhabited island in the Caribbean, called
采取一切力所能及的适当手段，促使该商品以合理的价格进口到国内。但是，菲尔莫尔大多只是说说而已，鸟粪价格继续飙升。于是，美国商人开始采取行动。他们开始寻找其他拥有新鸟粪来源的岛屿。这些鸟粪勘探者在加勒比海发现了一个无人居住的岛屿，名为
Abyss. In 1854, a group of Americans landed there to mine the guano and attempted to claim the island. That's Christina Duffy Ponsa. And I'm a law professor at Columbia. In Ponsa says that U.S. guano mining on Ava set off a minor diplomatic crisis. Venezuela felt that the island belonged to them and they ended up sending a warship to kick the guano company off the island.
纳瓦萨岛。1854年，一群美国人登陆那里开采鸟粪，并试图宣称拥有该岛。那是克里斯蒂娜·达菲·庞萨。我是哥伦比亚大学的法学教授。庞萨说，美国在纳瓦萨岛的鸟粪开采引发了一场小规模的外交危机。委内瑞拉认为该岛属于他们，最终派出一艘军舰将鸟粪公司赶出了岛屿。
But when they got home, the guano prospectors asked Congress to pass legislation that would protect them as they try to claim new islands. So, US citizens could feel like they had the backing of the US government if they encounter a controversy. Like military backing, meaning you guys can go out, take these islands, and if anyone shows up with warships, we'll bring ours too. And in the debate over this legislation, politicians argued about guano prices and other details, but there were also some senators who expressed a larger concern. They worried that by taking over islands for the purposes of mining guano, the United States could be perceived as having imperial aspirations.
但当他们回到家时，鸟粪勘探者要求国会通过立法，在他们试图宣称拥有新岛屿时保护他们。这样，如果美国公民遇到争议，他们会觉得有美国政府的支持。就像军事支持一样，意味着你们可以去占领这些岛屿，如果有人带着军舰出现，我们也会带上我们的。在关于这项立法的辩论中，政客们争论鸟粪价格和其他细节，但也有一些参议员表达了更大的担忧。他们担心，通过为了开采鸟粪而接管岛屿，美国可能会被视为有帝国野心。
Secretly trying to set up colonies and engage in territorial expansion by claiming islands in the Atlantic and the Pacific and all over the world. And a little context is important here. This is all happening against the backdrop of European colonialism. Great Britain is about to establish its colonial government in India, and various European countries will soon colonize nearly all of Africa. The United States had taken over much of North America and violently stole territory from indigenous people.
秘密试图建立殖民地，并通过宣称拥有大西洋、太平洋和世界各地的岛屿来进行领土扩张。这里需要一点背景。这一切都发生在欧洲殖民主义的背景下。英国即将建立其在印度的殖民政府，而各个欧洲国家很快将殖民几乎整个非洲。美国已经接管了北美大部分地区，并暴力窃取了原住民的领土。
But political leaders at the time didn't think of this as colonialism because the US always incorporated new territory into the country, rather than maintaining colonies. The US also prided itself on being a nation born out of a revolution against an imperial power. So the United States did then and has always conceived of itself as an anti-imperialist country and distinguished itself from European powers who in this period in the 19th century were acquiring territories all over the globe. And so even though in the case of the Guano Islands, they're talking about claiming uninhabited rocks,
但当时的政治领导人并不认为这是殖民主义，因为美国总是将新领土并入国家，而不是维持殖民地。美国也以自己是一个诞生于反抗帝国强权的革命的国家而自豪。因此，美国当时以及一直以来都将自己视为一个反帝国主义国家，并将自己与这一时期（19世纪）在世界各地获取领土的欧洲列强区分开来。所以，即使在鸟粪岛的情况下，他们谈论的是宣称拥有无人居住的岩石，
some senators think that this looks a little too close to colonialism for comfort. So they work on developing language that will mitigate any fears that the US is trying to set up overseas colonies. So eventually, as the Senate goes through a series of drafts, the way that the islands are described is not as part of the territory of the United States or subject to the sovereignty of the United States. Those words drop out. They are described as appertaining to the United States as in a sort of fancy old-fashioned way of saying belonging to? Appertaining. The thing about that word was that at the time no one really knew what it meant from
一些参议员认为这看起来太像殖民主义了，让人不安。因此，他们致力于制定措辞，以减轻人们对美国试图建立海外殖民地的担忧。因此，最终，随着参议院通过一系列草案，这些岛屿的描述方式不再是作为美国领土的一部分或受美国主权管辖。这些词被删除了。它们被描述为“从属于”（appertaining to）美国，这是一种花哨的、老式的说法，意为“属于”？“从属于”。关于这个词，当时没有人真正从
a legal perspective, but it was softer than saying, we own this, it's ours. The Senators also included an abandonment clause, which said that the United States could relinquish possession over the islands once the guano had been exhausted. And with all these cabyats in place in 1856, Congress passed the guano islands act. And at that point, American citizens start claiming islands all over the place. This is really companies that want to mind this guano. Start sending people out and telling them to claim these islands. In total, US companies claimed over the place. This is really companies that want to mine this guano. Start sending people out and telling them to claim these islands. In total, US companies claimed over 70 islands throughout the Pacific and the Caribbean.
法律角度知道它是什么意思，但它比说“我们拥有这个，它是我们的”要温和得多。参议员们还加入了一个放弃条款，规定一旦鸟粪耗尽，美国可以放弃对这些岛屿的占有。在所有这些限制条件到位后，1856年，国会通过了《鸟粪岛法案》。从那时起，美国公民开始到处宣称拥有岛屿。这实际上是那些想要开采鸟粪的公司。开始派人出去，告诉他们去宣称拥有这些岛屿。总共，美国公司宣称拥有了
Indigenous Polynesians and Hawaiians mined guano for US companies on bar-flung Pacific Islands. And after the Civil War, guano companies recruited free black men to mine guano on Caribbean islands. Like in Peru, mine Guano on Caribbean islands. Like in Peru, US Guano mining was brutal, and workers were often coerced and horribly mistreated. Guano Mania didn't last all that long in the end. By the 1870s, the vast Guano deposits
太平洋和加勒比海各地的70多个岛屿。原住民波利尼西亚人和夏威夷人在偏远的太平洋岛屿上为美国公司开采鸟粪。内战后，鸟粪公司招募自由黑人到加勒比海岛屿上开采鸟粪。就像在秘鲁一样，美国的鸟粪开采非常残酷，工人们经常受到胁迫和可怕的虐待。鸟粪狂热最终并没有持续太久。到19世纪70年代，钦查群岛上巨大的鸟粪沉积物
on the Chinchu Islands were almost gone. Many of the islands the United States took didn't turn out to have very good Guano deposits on the Chincha Islands were almost gone. Many of the islands the United States took didn't turn out to have very good guano. And synthetic fertilizers were just around the corner. And while the history of the Guano trade isn't often talked about, it had lasting impacts that are still incredibly relevant to this day. The Guano trade introduced the idea
几乎消失殆尽。美国占领的许多岛屿最终并没有很好的鸟粪沉积物。合成肥料也即将出现。虽然鸟粪贸易的历史并不常被提及，但它产生了至今仍极其相关的持久影响。鸟粪贸易引入了一个概念，
that soil fertility could be bought and sold. Instead of carefully tending to their soil on the farm, farmers could just buy this guano supplement and sprinkle it on their fields. This paved the way for the fertilizer-fueled industrial agriculture that we see today. And the Guano Islands Act set a precedent that would help enable future acts of American imperialism
即土壤肥力是可以买卖的。农民们不必在农场里精心照料土壤，只需购买这种鸟粪补充剂并撒在田地里即可。这为我们今天看到的以化肥为燃料的工业化农业铺平了道路。《鸟粪岛法案》开创了一个先例，将有助于促成未来美国在
on islands that were very much inhabited. Around the turn of the 20th century, the United States goes to war with Spain over the occupation of Cuba and the US winds. So after the Spanish-American war, what happens is the United States takes Puerto Rico and the Philippines and Guam, as basically part of its war booty for defeating Spain in Cuba. And to be clear, these territories were taken as spoils of war, not as part of the Guano Islands Act. But when the U.S. annexed these island territories in 1898, it sets off a huge debate about what to do next. You could make these places into states, but the white political establishment wasn't too excited about absorbing a bunch of islands full of people of color.
非常有人居住的岛屿上的帝国主义行为。20世纪之交，美国因占领古巴而与西班牙开战，美国获胜。因此，美西战争后，美国将波多黎各、菲律宾和关岛作为击败西班牙后的战利品。需要明确的是，这些领土是作为战争掠夺品被占领的，而不是作为《鸟粪岛法案》的一部分。但当美国在1898年吞并这些岛屿领土时，引发了一场关于下一步该做什么的巨大辩论。你可以把这些地方变成州，但白人政治建制派对吸收一大堆有色人种居住的岛屿并不太感兴趣。
It's about race, more than anything else. White Americans want the nation to be a white nation. So this is the same period of time in which Americans start tightening their immigration laws. But politicians were reluctant to give up territory with real strategic value. In 1901, this question about the status of Puerto Rico and the Philippines makes its way to the Supreme Court, in a case involving goods that are shipped from Puerto Rico to the United States.
这主要关乎种族。白人美国人希望国家成为一个白人国家。所以这与美国开始收紧移民法的时期相同。但政客们不愿放弃具有真正战略价值的领土。1901年，关于波多黎各和菲律宾地位的问题被提交到最高法院，涉及从波多黎各运往美国的货物。
The disputarizes around a shipment of oranges from Puerto Rico to New York. When the shipment arrives in New York, the customs collector imposes duties on the oranges as if they were coming from a foreign country. And the company shipping them challenges the duties, saying Puerto Rico is part of the United States. The Constitution says that you can't impose duties on any goods being shipped within the country. This case was about taxing oranges, but to decide this case,
争议围绕着一批从波多黎各运往纽约的橙子。当这批货物抵达纽约时，海关征收关税，就好像它们来自外国一样。运输货物的公司对关税提出质疑，称波多黎各是美国的一部分。宪法规定，不能对国内运输的任何货物征收关税。这个案件是关于对橙子征税的，但为了裁决此案，
the court would need to answer a bigger question. What relationship do these islands have to the United States? In the end, the court ruled that imposing a duty is okay, because these new places, Puerto Rico, Guam, the Philippines, are not fully a part of the United States. But in their decision, the justices make clear that they aren't foreign either. The famous phrase from these cases is that they're foreign to the United States in a domestic sense. It's an odd phrase. At the time, no one really knows what it means. It basically creates a limbo and in-between status.
法院需要回答一个更大的问题：这些岛屿与美国是什么关系？最终，法院裁定征收关税是可以的，因为这些新地方——波多黎各、关岛、菲律宾——并不完全是美国的一部分。但在裁决中，法官们明确表示它们也不是外国。这些案件中著名的短语是，它们在“国内意义上”对美国而言是外国。这是一个奇怪的短语。当时，没有人真正知道它是什么意思。它基本上创造了一个不确定的中间状态。
Some of the justices point it to the Guano Islands Act as a justification for creating this in-between status. And the ruling went on to say that these new territories were a pertinent to the United States, a pertinent as in appertaining. And there's that word, that word, appertaining from the Guano Islands context. When even then and after then, still, lawyers
一些法官指出《鸟粪岛法案》是创造这种中间状态的理由。裁决继续说，这些新领土是“从属于”（appertaining to）美国的，“从属于”即“从属于”。这就是那个词，那个来自鸟粪岛背景的词“从属于”。即使在当时和之后，律师们
trying to understand what that word means, can't quite make sense. They're never quite sure what, you know, all we know is this is a way of kind of holding a place at arm's length while still controlling it. It's impossible to know whether this case would have unfolded differently if the U.S. had never gone looking for Guano, but the Guano Islands set a precedent.
试图理解这个词的意思，也无法完全理解。他们从来不确定，你知道，我们所知道的是，这是一种在控制一个地方的同时又将其拒之门外的方法。如果美国从未去寻找鸟粪，这个案件是否会有不同的发展，这是不可能知道的，但鸟粪岛开创了一个先例。
And that gives the court a familiar and legitimate mode of reasoning in creating a status that was really an invention, a territory that belonged to the United States, but wasn't a state. And some of these territories still have this limbo status. Puerto Rico still has the status of a foreign, in a domestic sense, territory of the United States. And that's also the case for four other territories, the US Virgin Islands, the Commonwealth of the Northern Mariana Islands, Guam, and American Samoa. All these places are in a form of limbo.
这为法院提供了一种熟悉且合法的推理模式，创造了一种实际上是发明出来的地位：一个属于美国但不是州的领土。其中一些领土仍然处于这种不确定的状态。波多黎各仍然处于美国“国内意义上”的外国领土地位。其他四个领土也是如此：美属维尔京群岛、北马里亚纳群岛联邦、关岛和美属萨摩亚。所有这些地方都处于一种不确定的状态。
And the United States ambivalent relationship with extra territorial islands all started with the Guano Islands Act, a legal framework that allowed the U.S. to take control over a place without making it fully a part of the country. Puerto Rico is an estate, nor is it an independent nation. Puerto Ricans are U.S. citizens, but they can't vote in U.S. presidential elections. And Professor Ponsa, who is from Puerto Rico, says that being stuck in this colonial limbo, appertaining, but not belonging to the United States, has stalled progress on the island for over 100 years. Puerto Ricans have spent a lot of time in political energy trying to decide whether to pursue
美国与境外岛屿之间矛盾的关系始于《鸟粪岛法案》，这是一个法律框架，允许美国在不使其完全成为国家一部分的情况下控制一个地方。波多黎各既不是一个州，也不是一个独立的国家。波多黎各人是美国公民，但他们不能在美国总统选举中投票。来自波多黎各的庞萨教授说，陷入这种殖民地的不确定状态——从属于但并不属于美国——已经阻碍了该岛100多年的进步。波多黎各人花费了大量的时间和政治精力试图决定是否追求
statehood or independence. And it has done a great deal of harm in Puerto Rico because it distorts politics when you're arguing about questions as foundational as should we be a state or not, it really haunts Puerto Rico's political life. The Guano Islands Act is still law. In fact, in the 1990s, a man from California named Bill Warren tried to claim the abandoned island of Novasa as his own private Guano Island. He failed.
建州或独立。这在波多黎各造成了巨大的伤害，因为它扭曲了政治，当你争论像“我们是否应该成为一个州”这样基础的问题时，它确实困扰着波多黎各的政治生活。《鸟粪岛法案》仍然是法律。事实上，在20世纪90年代，一个名叫比尔·沃伦的加州人试图宣称废弃的纳瓦萨岛是他自己的私人鸟粪岛。他失败了。
But the U.S. still holds claim over a few of the old Guano Islands in the Pacific. Some of these islands ended up having some kind of strategic value as landing strips and they had other kinds of military uses. Amelia Earhart was planning to land on a guano island to refuel when her plane went down in the Pacific. And President Obama used guano island possessions to expand one of the largest marine reserves in the world. The guano islands in the Pacific that the U.S US still controls are now called the United States Minor Outline Islands. They don't have any permanent resonance, a few military officials and scientists live there throughout the year, but these little rocky islands are ongoing projections of the
但美国仍然对太平洋中的一些旧鸟粪岛拥有主权。其中一些岛屿最终作为飞机跑道具有某种战略价值，并有其他军事用途。阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特在太平洋坠机时，正计划降落在鸟粪岛上加油。奥巴马总统利用鸟粪岛的占有权扩大了世界上最大的海洋保护区之一。美国目前仍控制的太平洋鸟粪岛现在被称为“美国本土外小岛屿”。它们没有任何永久居民，只有少数军事官员和科学家全年居住在那里，但这些小岩石岛屿是
American Empire, and are a reminder about the time when Guano Mania gripped the world. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, with Sri Fusev, Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstead, Avery, Trouffman, Sam Green, Span, Delaney Hall, Terran Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. Special thanks to Professor Dan Margalees of Virginia, Westling College, and our pal, O.K. Akumi, who was a new album of previously unreleased tracks that's up on Bandcamp, and I'm really enjoying it a whole lot right now. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
美帝国持续的投射，也是对鸟粪狂热席卷世界那个时代的提醒。《99%隐形》本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，参与制作的还有斯里·富塞夫、凯蒂·明格尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、艾弗里·特劳夫曼、萨姆·格林、斯潘、德莱尼·霍尔、泰兰·马扎以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢弗吉尼亚韦斯特林学院的丹·马格里斯教授，以及我们的朋友O.K.阿库米，他有一张新专辑，收录了之前未发行的曲目，现在在Bandcamp上，我非常喜欢。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的广播街制作。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But if you want to be super interesting at your holiday party, I recommend you spend some time reading a few stories at 99PI.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们在Instagram和Tumblr上也有账号。但如果你想在节日派对上表现得超级有趣，我建议你花点时间在99PI.org上阅读一些故事。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。